a two-time Olympic gold medalist Carly
Lloyd she's a soccer player she has just
made a
shocking declaration she has
declared that men are better at soccer
than women she has this this woman has
just declared that men are better at
sports than women can you imagine
because someone responded to her and
said hey is it true that you guys lost
to a bunch of 15-year-old boys you
sometimes hear this that the women's
soccer team the professional women's
soccer team lost to a group of
15-year-old boys and she she responds
and goes yeah that's true I know
thousands of people have already brought
that up the boys were good we actually
lost to a youth Bayern Munich team in my
career as well but then we went on to
win the Olympics in the world cup
so yeah we we lost to boys because we're
girls but then we beat other girls
because we're relatively better at
soccer than other girls she goes haha
they should beat us they should the boys
should beat us they're bigger stronger
and faster boys always gave us a run for
our money and that was great prep what a
great attitude this woman almost could
get me to like
soccer because that's the right answer
yes the boys beat us this is not a mark
of Shame this is not something we need
to hide the boys beat us they're boys
vivla defance this is yes that's good
that boys beat us and we can actually
work with the boys they can help us
train to beat the girls because we
acknowledge reality we know that they
are better at this than us that's that's
that's the right attitude sexual
difference and you
see the
feminists men and women are totally
wrong on this where they pretend men and
women are exactly the same and it ends
up creating meoo and rape culture and
all the terrible pathologies that infect
the relation between the sexist today
but you even see this
among the red pill kind of movement
which they bring up a lot of legitimate
gripes so I don't want to knock the red
pill guys too much but their conclusions
often are very wrong and they discuss
the difference between and women with
anger you know these these women are so
different than we are or or these these
men are are barbarians or what you know
they even try to behave like barbarians
sometimes but the difference between the
Sexes is something to be celebrated it's
lovely it's delightful I'd like that if
the Sexes were exactly the same that
would make us all gay guys and then and
that would be which I guess there are a
lot of gay guys today and we have a very
confused sexual culture today but the
fact that men and women are different
you say oh good women they're so diff I
can't even I can't understand them
they're they're so strange they don't
they drive me crazy in many ways but
isn't that fun one of the joys of life
right now text noes to 98 9898 yet again
we are facing the threat of a government
shutdown later this month and yet again
the administration will deal with it the
same way they always do with more
spending more spending will inevitably
devalue the dollar protect your savings
by diversifying into gold with the help
of Birch gold group here's the best part
when you open an IRA with Birch gold for
every $10,000 you spend by December 22nd
Birch gold will send you a free gold bar
just text Nes kws to 98 9898 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
without taking any money out of pocket
are you listening you get a free gold
bar multiple free gold bars depending on
how much money you put in with an A+
rating with a Better Business Bureau and
thousands of satisfied customers you can
count on Birch gold to help you
transition an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold do not let your savings
fall victim to the further devaluation
of the dollar Tex nles kwes to 98 9898
receive a free info kit on gold claim
your eligibility before Black Friday to
receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles text
it to 98 9898 right now go to Ruff
greens.com the holidays are coming up
fast and while you're out shopping for
your kids your family your friends don't
forget to shop for your pets too give
your dog the gift of a healthier and
happier life with Ruff greens
naturopathic do Dennis black the founder
of Ruff greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America dog
food might as well be considered dead
food if you ask me because it contains
very little nutritional value is
nutrition Brown no one might say it's
green which is why you got to let rough
greens bring your dog's food back to
life rough greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food just sprinkle those tasty
juicy little rough Greens on their food
every day dog owners are raving about it
I even send it to my stepbrother for his
little miniature Australian shepherd so
right now you can get a free jumpstart
trial bag so that your dog can try it
you get a free FWE baby jump start trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com or call 844 r123 that is rfff
greens /el m i AEL or call 844 Ru ff1
123 today the FBI has seized New York
city mayor Eric Adams's phone and iPad
amid a federal corruption
investigation this is very strange
because New York city mayor Eric Adams
he's a
Democrat he's a fairly liberal Democrat
but actually recently mayor Adams has
has been saying some things that the
Liberals don't like
so the allegations here are that mayor
Adams's 2021 campaign colluded with the
Turks usually we talk about colluding
with the Russians or colluding with the
ukrainians sometimes colluding with the
Chinese this is a new one apparently
Eric Adams colluded with the Turks all
right add that to the list the
allegation is that he received illegal
campaign donations from the Turkish
government and what are those donations
according to the New York Post campaign
records show that mayor Adams accepted
$66,000 from three donors who served on
a board backed by the son of the Turkish
president
erdogan
seriously that hold on let me did I get
that must be $6 million right no 600,000
no not even 60 thou
$6,000 from three donors who are on a
board with the son of the leader of this
hold on this isn't this isn't adding up
to me
until I realized wait a second this
doesn't have anything to do with
campaign donations the reason that the
libs and the liberal enforcement
institution the FBI are going after
Adams right now is cuz he said this
110,000 th000
migrants we have to feed clothe house
educate the children watch their laundry
sheets give them everything they need
health care we're getting no support on
this National crisis and we're receiving
no support and let me tell you something
New
Yorkers never in my life have I had a
problem that I did not see in ending to
I don't see an ending to
this I don't see an ending to this this
issue will destroy New York City destroy
New York City there it is oh boy there
it is this was my first reaction when I
saw the headline Eric Adams investigated
I thought oh that guy piped up a little
too much about immigration didn't he
that was his mistake it I don't think it
has to do with $6,000 from some people
who once went to a Turkish bath on 11th
street or something I don't think it's
because a couple guys ate Falafel one
day and they gave Eric Adams a high five
and now he's under investigation
nah this guy spoke up against something
that the Liberals have to support which
is endless Mass migration and he he
broke the script
here and he he broke with the
long-standing Democrat tradition of
flooding the country with foreign
Nationals and in particular he
criticized Joe Biden he's saying Joe
Biden your policy is bad he embarrassed
the sitting Democrat president and then
what do you know the highly politicized
investigative and law enforcement arm
run ultimately by that President starts
poking around Eric Adams's cell phone
and
iPad looks like someone spoke up a
little too much and then I I don't want
to be a tinfoil hack guy I really don't
want to defend a Democrat mayor of New
York but I got to go where the facts
lead me and in the reporting on this
investigation into Adams says following
news of the investigation Adams canceled
his plan to discuss illegal immigration
and the Border crisis with the Biden
Administration there we go I hadn't even
read that part before I came to my
conclusion my kner conclusion this has
got to be about illegal immigration
which it is so now they start
threatening Adams and he says okay okay
I'll back off okay we I won't I won't
meet with the Biden admin to talk about
this problem okay I'll cool it and stop
admitting that illegal immig I stop
admitting publicly at least that illegal
immigration will destroy New York City
which we all know including the liberal
Democrat mayor man what a great clip
that was now hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
you got to ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel see you
next time